before you embark on an epic space  mission you need a crew that can handle  anything  anything  buzz lightyear elite space ranger  unwavering hero mission leader roger  that  izzy hawthorne super motivated the  junior patrol has your back maybe a tiny  bit scared of space oh that's a lot of  space okay very scared  morrison aka moe curious observer a bit  of a dabbler oh look a pen cool open to  new experiences except for being killed  by robots  not open to that particular experience  no  derby a real no-nonsense gruff type who  can take any three objects and make them  explode  now that's satisfying  and of course socks personal companion  robot designed with cutting-edge  technology an essential part of the team  i see you i'm gonna get you i'm gonna  get you oh i didn't get you the socks  where'd you go oh my god socks oh yeah  sorry come meet the entire gang don't  miss disney and pixar's light year only  in theaters this friday  you